you guys completely moved across the
pacific to have this job you did it
uh yeah it was a talk that i had with my
husband and i said what do you think and
he's like okay first of all like sure
we're going to talk about it but he's
like hawaii
um it could be worse he's like dude this
is awesome and i'll never forget
his exact words were this is your time
and it's not that he hasn't been there
for me in the past to support me but
we've definitely
we really do try a 50 50 when he's on
tour i try to be home when i'm shooting
something he tries to be home we decided
to start shooting things together like
love is blind and
other stuff on netflix and so we're like
oh this is working this is a thing that
would take our whole family out of the
mainland and bring them very far away
and he was on board to support me and i
told the kids and they were gung-ho
because they think that hawaii is water
slides and plates
all the time yeah even now though it's
it's great i ask them all the time i'm
like are you happy and they're like yeah
like they love it here they're island
babies i didn't even realize i had
island babies until i brought them here
and i'm like i have island babies i love
the image obviously the babies are
highland babies and they started school
here how are they adjusted kids are more
resilient than adults i do believe i
learned that on top chef junior like
when we would have to send a kid home i
would go home me and curtis still and
i'm like i'm devastated and the next day
the kid was like hey what's up do you
mind signing my book for me and i'm like
you're okay he's like yeah i met new
friends and i got to learn
to learn a new dish
our kids i think that this is extremely
important for them a lot of people don't
have the luxury to be able to relocate
whether it's you know for work or
financial so i don't take that for
granted but we are definitely welcoming
it with open arms and i went to eight
different schools my first nine years of
school
that was a lot and i wouldn't change
anything and how it it made me but um i
can imagine how much stress that was on
my parents now that i'm in it but for my
kids it's great it's great because i
think that there's something that you
can't teach your children
the whole leading by example versus like
telling them
when they see different kids in
different states and different cultures
and different
economic backgrounds they understand
that some things are different but also
a lot of things are the same and so they
understand empathy they understand
kindness they understand the universal
love
but um
it's great because i i i just want them
to be in a more multicultural lifestyle
and i believe hawaii specifically oahu
is that for our family and i love it i
love that they just see kids as kids and
this is the norm
you know what i think
this is a crime scene
jane tennant special agent in charge
ncis hawaii what do they think of mom's
new job when you tell them maybe about
like the stunts that you're doing or
some of the action what do they think
he's a cool mom i it's funny because
camden probably grasps it and
understands it the most in terms of like
oh you're on tv i'll never forget when
he first went to school and he was in
kindergarten someone's like i saw your
mom or i saw your dad i mean nick was on
the math singer every kid knows that
show they're like your dad is piglet but
what's been interesting is my
six-year-old so brooklyn is my daughter
boy girl boy and i took her to my very
first stunt session nick had the two
boys and i took her because we try not
to leave all three with one you know if
they're solo and i said i'll take her
it's no big deal you can have the boys
and you guys go they went to the skate
park
and what i didn't realize was somebody
texted me they're like you might have a
little stunty on your hands and i'm like
wait a minute i'm exposing her to it was
my first fight scene so she saw me doing
the fake punches doing you know the gun
work doing all of this and she just sat
there i brought her crayons and paper
but she just sat there watching me then
when i showed her the trailer she just
sat there with these like i had it was
the most proud mom mom and i don't see
stars in her eyes because that sounds
really but when it was over i'm like b
what do you think and she was like
like i could tell she had this that's my
mom moment you know what i mean phoenix
was four he was like hey do we have a
snack and kim was like that's really
cool he actually liked more of the
camera work and the stunts and all that
she just saw me and she was like yes and
that
look i want to do it for both of my you
know for
my boys and my daughter
but it was a really cool moment that my
daughter could see her mom being a
badass
i thought this was just gonna be a job
but i've realized that it's a lot more
we're practically family here
when the moon